hey youtubers is Charlie because Comic
Con was last weekend and Korra just went
all digital I'm gonna be combining my
episode 8 in episode 9 reviews in this
video I'll also explain what's going on
with the show - don't worry nothing bad
is happening nothing bad I also have a
bunch of stuff to give away so I will
announce which people won giveaways at
the end of this video because I had
three different ones going on this past
week so in case you're finding me for
the first time I do core videos every
week be sure to subscribe to get
everything we only have a couple
episodes left in the season but I will
be doing some bonus content efforts over
I mostly want to focus on episode 9 in
this video but real quick here's some
things worth mentioning about episode 8
first off best fight scene all season
team Zaheer vs. team Korra
I feel like the Red Lotus people are so
well-trained the Corps is just gonna
keep getting her ass handed to her
whenever she engages them in combat it's
like fighting a bunch of unlocks at once
meaning Cora's gonna have to find a
non-combat solution to defeat Zaheer
it's not gonna end with a bending match
fire ferrets style but I do think that
the metalbending foosball game will come
back at some point or at least I hope it
does just imagine Bolin bouncing metal
balls all over a bunch of stuff taking
people down I definitely think that he's
gonna learn to metalbend this season at
some point even though Iowa turned out
to be the obvious trader I feel like
soo-eun has involved somehow like she's
involved with the Red Lotus technically
they're not an evil organization but she
is way too sanguine about Korra safety
especially letting her go so quickly and
that person in her circus photo from
when she was younger
looks just like Zaheer wearing clown
makeup she even talked about how
ridiculous she thought it was that the
earth Kingdom still had a queen and even
if she's not a full-on member she feels
like she's a collaborator which is just
as bad as for vark I feel like his
magnetic technology will come in handy
in some unexpected way
like he'll help team Korra take down the
metal benders if it turns out that suyun
really is working with the Red Lotus
aside from that the Airbender finding
device feels like a bit of a dead end
the only way I see that coming back is
if Korra uses it to find an Airbender in
like a crowd of people like if Zaheer
tries to airbend against them and then
hide in a crowd they use it to find him
I didn't like the pacing in the episode
quite as much as some of the others so I
gave it a B overall the animation was
amazing though especially the animation
during the fight scenes it was just
brilliant studio Mir has done an amazing
job this season so every time I want to
give Mike Bryan in the cast to high five
I have to remember to give Studio Mir
- so moving on to episode 9 I feel like
it was a lot more important just because
we got that really good explainer
careful for spoilers if you have not
seen it yet but I'll also explain at the
end of this video about where and when
to watch new Korra episodes so starting
with top five moments here we go
number five Bolin's fandom I feel like
you could single out several Bolin
moments but they're all about him being
a mover star you can tell he really
misses it macha oh macha oh macha oh
macha once book four is over I hope they
all get to settle down and start their
own families but I want to see Bolin
start his own mover studio so he could
just make movers for the rest of his
life his superfans were by far the
funniest moment in the episode and while
Mike and Bryan and the writers were
responsible for the dialogue I wonder if
they're poking fun at their fans or at
Janet Varney fans they're not being mean
or anything it's just all meant to be
silly but I feel like I've seen people
like that at comic-con the thing that
made it so much funnier was that they
animated him is like these big giant
street thugs that look kind of scary
they just turned out to be harmless
superfans maybe that's the way Mike and
Bryan view the Korra fandom like really
intense looking and sounding but
secretly totally harmless you can let me
know if you agree but if any of you guys
are going to New York comic-con Korra is
going to your comic-con I'm probably
gonna be there but if you get the chance
to ask them a question or when they're
on stage or take a picture with them try
to get them to re-enact that scene it
would be so hilarious to get Janet
Varney to like stroke her hair while PJ
Byrne makes that weird face it would be
the most perfect animated gifs of the
cast ever but going back to familiar
territory now number four the desert
oasis animation and it's really not a
specific moment but it's just the
animation during all the desert oasis
scenes
whenever you see Maiko and Bolin
entering Korra on the hill looking down
it's just so beautiful the way that they
did it I know a lot of you guys
subscribed to me whenever I was doing
videos for book two last year and one of
the biggest complaints that I saw was
that you guys really did not dig the
animation just because it was a
different studio the only reason that
studio Mir didn't animate all the book 2
was really just scheduling conflicts in
manpower during the comic-con panel
Bryan Kinetico even said that studio Mir
had to call on some help to animate book
4 stuff they're actually in the middle
of that right now
it just takes an army of people to do
animation just as a point of comparison
a couple years ago whenever they were
making the simpsons movie Matt Groening
said that they were doing the TV show
and the movie at the same time so what
they had to do they needed so many
people that they literally
every single animator in Hollywood that
was not already locked under contract to
other TV shows that's a shitload of
people but now let's start peeling open
the Red Lotus number three Korra and
Zaheer meet in the spirit realm so here
is totally using the spirit realm to
Skype with the other Red Lotus members
which I feel is just ingenious I feel
like they probably been doing that for a
long time I also really liked how Zaheer
stalled Korra by luring her into that
long explainer speech about who they
were he really didn't explain his plan
but I'm gonna separate a few bits from
those spirit realm scenes just because
they were all really important as for
aiwei do not feel too bad for him he
could probably find jazz somewhere in
the fog of lost souls and they can talk
about how much they hate avatars maybe
they can even play some PI show if I
broke and have tea parties alice in
wonderland style you could probably play
PI show which reminds me number two
Bolin gets his ass handed to him in PI
show by Asami it's not so much about
them playing PI show against each other
it just PI shows a metaphor for chorus
conflict with Sahir as well as a here's
plot in the Red Lotus in general it just
works on all levels it's great Korra for
instance let's talk about her conflict
was to hear Asami said that in order to
defeat your opponent in PI show first
you have to know them and Korra does not
know Zaheer yet even though she got that
big explainer speech I do think in the
next one or two episodes she'll figure
him out figure out what the plan really
is and then she'll be able to formulate
a strategy and then this is the long
game formulating a strategy to defeat
your opponent over a long period of time
that's like Zaheer in the Red Lotus
trying to topple the world's governments
clearly they've been planning to do that
for a long time
infiltrating all aspects of society luan
Locke was a bit of a wild card which was
also a pretty awesome WTF reveal too
which leads me to my number one moment
unlock was part of the Red Lotus he was
in on everything but when the whole plot
to capture Korra went south he covered
it up and let's see here and the rest of
the group rot in jail I love that Zaheer
explained that the whole dark avatar
stuff from last year the UNA vaatu stuff
was just him going rogue it implies that
the Red Lotus as an organization is not
evil it's just a group of fanatics that
are so stuck on bringing balance that
air every once in a while one of them
ends up hurting a lot of people or in
the case of unlock almost destroying
everyone everywhere I still feel like
that's only half the story and Korra
still got a lot to find out about what
his ultimate plan is and woodsey here's
motivations are he said that he didn't
want to kill her but I think that we
heard him say
opposite of that in an earlier episode
so he might be saying contradictory
things either way I don't think he's
just another unlock I don't think that
he cares about power I just think city
wants to burn down the old world so that
a new one can rise in the ashes
presumably based on what he said about
avatar Wan he wants things to be more
like what they were before raava and
vaatu were separated and if he could
find a way to bring the line turtles
back
I would totally back his plan I would
fund that Kickstarter either way now
it's your turn let me know in the
comments below what was your favorite
moment and do you feel like su Yin is
part of the Red Lotus is she in on it
remember they've been around since right
after the hundred year war so there's
probably a lot of members that we have
not met yet overall I gave the episode
an a-minus
mostly because it explains so many
things I was so happy a lot of you guys
had already been asking about the Red
Lotus just because there were some
spoilers floating around as well as some
info on future episodes but I really
like the way they use PI show to inform
their splinter group like using it is an
offshoot of the white lotus tile that
formed the name of the White Lotus
organization I feel like some of the
wiser members of the White Lotus will
know more about the Red Lotus like Zuko
will probably know a little bit about
them we haven't seen him in a while
hopefully he's gonna come back in the
next couple of episodes in terms of new
characters Henry Rollins has been so
amazing as I hear he is so perfect for
that role he's actually a super
interesting person in real life if
you're not familiar with them it goes
way beyond him being a musician here's a
picture that Mike and Bryan had made of
him whenever they cast him just to honor
the fact that he was a punk rocker I'll
say the only thing that I'm disappointed
about so far is that we haven't got to
know a lot about the other members of
his group like they haven't got their
own origin stories to be fair we still
haven't got enough fools to hear origin
story either we only know that at some
point in his teenage years he joined the
Red Lotus we don't understand why he's
so passionate about their cause like did
he lose someone close to him during the
hundred year war or is he related to
someone else in the order
wouldn't it be totally crazy if he was
like suyun and beifong's brother the
next episode is gonna be a bit of a
twist I feel like he and his team will
end up trying to join Korra from
underneath the earth Queens thumb in the
Dai Li for a second I actually thought
that he might be using the earth Queen
is like a puppet to top all the other
governments of the world
you like her marching her Airbender army
and destroying the other governments for
him but now I feel like they're
completely separate entities and here's
an interesting thought think about so
here is being like The Dark Knight Joker
of
Koro world right now he just wants to
watch the world burn
dot dot dot so that a new one can grow
in its place but it reminds you a lot of
Heath Ledger in Dark Knight he's like an
agent of chaos plus he looks like he
used to play a joker in soohyun's circus
group so now just to explain a little
bit about all the WTF with Korra going
off the air and going all digital Mike
and Bryan explained pretty clearly at
Comic Con that they originally
Nickelodeon had a place in plan to just
air digitally like the way it is right
now on the website it's very convenient
and it doesn't have all those spammy ads
that you see on those other sites where
people stream it at some point that plan
changed and they put it back on the air
but then it leaked plants changed again
on top of all that Korra doesn't really
fit with their other programming very
well like it's not spongebob so they had
a much harder time marketing it so as a
result Korra is going all digital for
the remainder of book 3 and book 4 so
that means they're never gonna air new
episodes on TV again they're just gonna
air new episodes digitally they are
they're just gonna release them
digitally here are the places that you
can watch it every Friday at 12 p.m.
Eastern Time new episodes are released
on nick.com on the Nickelodeon website
you can also buy episodes in the Amazon
store and on iTunes personally I would
just recommend that you guys watch it
for free on the NIC website but if you
live in another country and the content
is blocked because of region or
something like that
there's tons of really easy guides on
Google about how to get around that kind
of stuff so new episodes gonna air each
week starting 12:00 p.m. Eastern Time
every Friday there are no more breaks
before the end of book 3 so be happy
about that we don't have a release date
for book 4 but they're probably gonna
announce something hopefully by the
finale okay so real quick shout out to
all the winners of the giveaway I have
three different giveaways running so
congratulations to James kung you win
the plushie doll you can pick like Naga
or Pabu I'll basically message you to
ask which one you want and then Kenneth
lore and Joe Joe Allen you guys win gift
cards from the episode video from last
week so I'll message all you guys for
details on your channels so be sure to
check your inboxes since I did two
episodes in this video I'm also going to
be giving away two more gift cards in
next week's Korra video so I'm still
catching up but hopefully by the end of
this week I'll be back on schedule also
since Court is gonna be over a little
bit sooner feel free to leave me
suggestions about you know anime videos
or Korra or other things to do while we
wait for book 4 to get here because
Court is gonna be gone in a couple weeks
but be sure to subscribe to get
everything and right now if you haven't
seen it click here to watch the Korra
Comic Con panel it was a lot of fun and
click here to get my episode citizen 7
video thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
[Music]